tonight's starting pitcher for the
tigers is spencer turnbull he's never
faced uh the cubs before so this is the
first time he's faced the cubs and we're
going to watch him early in this game to
see his command that's going to be the
biggest issue for him
and the first pitch swung on and sent to
deep left reyes on the run and he's got
it shy of the wall
not an easy play first play of the game
there's still a little bit of sun out
there in left field
rizzo sends it to left volunteers very a
nice running grab by victor reyes wow
boy he's logged a lot of
miles already in left field hasn't he
seven pitches two outs
here comes miguel cabrera the 1-1 driven
right
that'll drop should drive in reyes hits
the bag hard at third no throw to home
tigers have the early lead that's the
miguel cabrera that we're kind of
accustomed to seeing
he wasn't trying to do anything except
hit the ball up the middle the other way
took what he got inside out a little bit
but he put the barrel to it bases are
loaded for jacoby jones
sent to right hayward drifting back and
he's got it
on the warning track cabrera trots home
tigers add to their lead it's
two-nothing detroit
good for jacob he got the job done there
he hit it far enough
to right field
miguel cabrera scores for the second run
of the game
there's dwayne underwood jr he will face
jamer candelario with the bases loaded
here's the pitch
swing and a miss that's a big one for
underwood two down
not a great pitch but a good result an
87 mile an hour change up that was up
and off the plate candelario couldn't
help himself nico goodroom here's the
one-two on the way swinging a missed
right three what a job by dwayne
underwood jr
back-to-back strikeouts he gets out of
the jam no runs for the tigers
here's the payoff
it was foul ball left side paradis has
room
big out huge
snaps back back in half dynamite effort
from spencer turnbull just three hits
no runs and he struck out five he
frustrated chicago all night so much
so that jason hayward did that
cameron maven steps to the plate to walk
in the bounce out
maven there you go that's into the left
field corner now you can run yeah and he
can run for a while santiago says go
ahead
jones hits the bag hard the relay is not
gonna get him
jones scores maybe yeah first stay there
stay there
there's an insurance run for you jack
mavin gets his first hit of the night
doubles down the line fourth time
they've loaded the bases here tonight
now jonathan scope stands in they left
three on in the first they left three on
in the third you don't want to do that
here
2-1 belton deep left get out of here sia
grand slam for jonathan scope
what a night for the tigers
wow chef that's the hit that they were
looking for in the situation that they
needed it jonathan scope how clutch has
he been
clears the bases with one swing and that
just gives the tigers a way
way more breathing room
home run number seven on the year
the second grand slam for the tigers
this season
and they have kicked the door open
buck farmer
making his 10th appearance trying to get
the final three outs tonight
tonight
out into deep left center gone
a home run for contreras
so the cubs will not be shut out tonight
it's 7 to one
talked about baez last night needing uh
something good to happen contrast
likewise has really been scuffling so
perhaps this will get him going a little
bit
[Music]
consolation prize but a home run
nonetheless
a very good swing of the bat his first
homer in exactly three weeks
here's the o2
struck him out
first pitch swinging
easy play for nico goodroom
chicago's last hopes resting with david
bodie
now the o2
swung on and missed him buck farmer
strikes out a pair in the ninth
and helps the tigers preserve the win
over chicago 7-1 the final the series is
even spencer turnbull leads the way and
gets big help from jonathan scope
with the grand slam home run and the
tigers pull away from the cubs
and even up the series at a game of
peace the five run sixth inning the
difference in the game our final score
the detroit tigers seven and the chicago
cubs won